who
Oh
- I shall are more like what I've met to
live a better care to brothers and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
are doing well obviously with this video
we wanted to a little experiment as you
know through the media it's time I
phobia is on the rise attacks towards
sisters brothers walking out on the
street it's on now hi so obviously what
we said was okay let's put this to the
test and get a few sisters was obviously
observing the DES cab as you guys know
the Islamic clothing so before I let
them go outside see what kind of
reactions are we going to get are they
going to get a tagger they're going to
get looked after you're going to be kind
happy we're going to react to the way
they are and the way they dress Tommy
see we do the experiment and let's go
and see what really happens
okay
it's all over
responses
you
hi excuse me Germany are job vacancies
do you have a senior nor me at the
moment no but okay you have to find a
manager stupid okay thank you for your
time
you
excuse me do you know they've got any
vacancies at the moment not in this
store I don't think these all done
online oh okay that's what's going on
I'll play nice TV there oh thanks yeah
I'm dude have you got any job vacancies
at the moment for what Kirk I go yeah
yeah I'm afraid not but try you know the
board upstairs because I think my
manager has pulled a full time oh okay
so if you want to check and if you have
a sous vide you I drop it with me and I
can let her know she just left now I
haven't got it on me ball come back yeah
if you come back I think she put the job
vacancy already but if you come back
we'll look at it and then give you okay
thank you um you got the job my kisses
at the moment and Jamie have to go into
HR which on the phone yeah I stopped for
all this up first okay yeah also
heavenly the like all the different
vacancies everywhere has are so if you
go to the third floor I'm just all
someone up there because it's sort of
like hidden in a corner yeah it's like
oh the outside yeah I think I'm Scott do
you think this will be a problem to work
in I'd I think they only cuz aren't like
from what you know he drive as well our
friend Cecil yes Oh office I know her
yes I think she wears that when she goes
outside you have to show your face but
you're allowed to way of scar oh I don't
think the whole thing yeah see that I
would have to compromise that yeah yeah
okay I think that all done like if they
maybe an interview and stuff like that
probably talk like they say if you wore
this in the interview how would you
reckon it will go like or you this best
take it off yeah or maybe like could you
request I wouldn't a woman too
yeah basically when you go up there
they've got one board which has like all
of the construction concession vacant
yeah and then one is if I need to go
into HR you can just kinda door to be if
you won't bother about possession just
anywhere oh they accept you for like MIT
combat and yeah and you could ask her
about your yeah cuz she knows about you
alright this asking hey clouds are there
really know something yeah okay alright
thank you so much go through hi Jeremy
I'm job breaking Sue's other moment oh
yeah I think we have it okay no right do
we hand in our CV here that will be
demos okay no online sorry
no online you want a hard copy yeah yeah
okay thank you for your help and if you
go on to your careers at Hollister home
and this is the passwords me 32 and you
can apply online okay um yeah and then
the interviews are on Thursday you can
use from for so you can put whenever
you're free to come in for an interview
it's also dress formal so if is not
going to be a certain dress code so
everything for religious purposes is
accepted okay thank you very much okay
there you go that's alright
excuse me madam I will just we're just
doing an experiment just one weapon do
anything okay we're a man what's up at
what are you for real
yeah what what happened I didn't do
anything I was walking up the stairs I'm
just wondering 60 years of age she for
real what did she want she do what did
she do
excuse me kids to me of doing something
okay
okay ashisu we came down the stairs into
the dragon's lair oops and I'm walking
down and sneaking up and she kicks me in
my leg
Oscar why did you kick me he said I
didn't kick you notice my leg my leg
hurts
and also the commissioners nice oh
you're crazy okay
so excuse me can I ask you a question
love do you know what McDonald's is
Donna yeah I have gonna be in here all
right thank you for stoppin thank you
excuse me MGA embankment is in that men
embankment
that's all right you can okay I think
it's just down the road there and then
you get to Waterloo yeah and then I
think it's that directly yeah thank you
you guys know what embankment is so what
site you know our embankment is back
Center down up like this way soon yeah
okay
yeah very much on you Roy all right
thank you it's me would you better take
a picture for our space on my phone yeah
I've got my camera right you just
pressed it you know the middle budget
yeah thank you but um with maybe the
clock in the background yeah amber can
you take pictures thank you thank you
thank you thank you how is that chick
sorry excuse me I'm Katella Waterloo
station is please don't kick the same
you go up here myself I kids yeah go
down the side of it that way
well that's side of the bridge and then
just keep going oh it's down there yes
exactly that all right thank you very
much Dory's color thank you we're gonna
go get lost
yeah who's me
sorry to stop you we're just doing like
um an experiment I just want to ask like
would you guys think of what I'm wearing
why do I wear it kind of thing I think I
was always the weird guy thank you very
much you're very beautiful yourself um I
just wouldn't need themI when genes or
yeah just normal clothes I like fashion
is what I did fashion College
you can't
do you know how old I am I'm 18 so I
don't have a husband
my dad does not like it so it's why once
where and because I want to
why do you want I am for me I lived a
different life before I had everything
out you know everything out and I found
when I spoke to guys
the only thing yes yes yeah that's all
I'm getting no respect no one's
listening to me no is engaging with my
brain I found like this I have control
over my own self when you're speaking to
me when you judge me if are she stupid
is she nice you're listening to my words
and watching my brain you're not judging
me on how I visit so for me I found this
um I find a phone is like empowering for
me our volunteers approach you I think
the answer the time or directions okay
how do you feel feel when you see like a
Muslim movement do you feel threatened
that could also you know that the media
perception you feel a bit worried back
go and they up to you or is it just you
just see them as normal individuals
let's say you're only from the west
country where you don't see a norm yeah
yeah okay I just wanted to ask um would
you guys think about what I'm wearing
like because of the news and wherever or
what you know about going to different
countries what do you guys think about
what we were I don't like it you don't
like it no I don't like it at all okay
I'm going to be bit so we don't know I
wouldn't be honest yes they're prettier
I don't like it because I think women
before us has had fought a lot for all
our rights
uh-huh and this is going back to losing
part of our rights okay so that's what I
think okay
of course I respect you is your do you
think a little bit yeah Christine that's
me okay
did you know the before I'm talking
about women's rights and suffer 1400
years ago you knew we believe in the
Prophet Muhammad yeah peace be upon him
a lot of time people would like bury
their daughters alive and stuff like
that at that time when people were doing
that he would walk down the street
holding his daughter's hand when she
came into the room he would gallop him
tell it sit down there and like the
first University was for women and it
was by Muslims in Morocco okay guys well
welcome back and as you saw for yourself
guys
to be honest we was there obviously a
recording without team and
we witnessed these kind of stuff and how
people would look in but in all in oil
and even though that attack that took
place people looking really weird etc
etc I think in totality brain is not as
Islamophobic as we think because yes we
did get a few odd looks etc here and
there but in total like I said before I
think brain is really tolerant again
against Muslims and I think it's those a
few individual bigots who obviously as
you know in every blood in every
community that black sheep so obviously
I think I'm going to leave that that no
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video share it spread the message
especially with the non-muslim friends
thanks for watching assalamu alaikum wa
rahmatullah wa barakato